Okay, guys, I'm just walked to my mailbox. I'm going through my mail. That's what I got here. I got a jury notice. Probably toss that. I have a sweepstakes. I should probably enter that. I have a utility bill that's going to be turned off.
好的，伙计们，我刚走到邮箱那儿。我正在翻看邮件。这就是我拿到的东西。我收到了一张陪审团传票。大概会把它扔掉。我还有一张抽奖券。我大概应该参加一下。我还有一张快要停电的电费单。
All my light's going to be turned off. Okay, I should probably toss that. Oh, what's this? Let me open this really quick. It's an all-new smart list right now. Guys, guess what's coming up in a couple weeks? Yeah, yeah, I know. We've got to mention.
我所有的灯都要被关掉了。好吧，我大概应该把它扔掉。哦，这是什么？让我赶紧打开看看。现在是一个全新的智能列表。伙计们，猜猜几周后会发生什么？是的，是的，我知道。我们必须提一下。
Oh, my God. You have the Hollywood Bowl. Hollywood Bowl. We're going to be at the Hollywood Bowl October 17th. And not just there, like not hanging out, actually doing a show. We're going to be on the stage. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And if you don't have tickets yet, you go to smartlist.com slash live, is that right?
哦，天哪。你们有露天剧场。露天剧场。我们10月17日要在露天剧场演出。不仅仅是在那里，不是闲逛，而是真的要表演一场秀。我们要上台了。是的，是的，是的，是的。如果你还没有票，就去smartlist.com斜杠live，是这样吗？
Wait, what's it? What is it? Smartlist.com slash live. Oh, my gosh, that's pretty easy. And for that, they're going to get a double guest. Is that right? Yep. Two guests.
等等，是什么？是什么？Smartlist.com斜杠live。哦，天哪，那太简单了。而且为此，他们会得到一位双重嘉宾。是这样吗？是的。两位嘉宾。
Yeah. And we got some fun, we got some fun surprises. Oh, yeah. Really? Yeah, we got some fun. prices. All for the price of one ticket. Yeah, all for the price of one ticket. And a nice, beautiful October, October 17th,
是的。我们还有一些有趣的，我们还有一些有趣的惊喜。哦，是的。真的吗？是的，我们有一些有趣的。价格。所有这些都只要一张票的价格。是的，所有这些都只要一张票的价格。在一个美好的十月，10月17日，
correct, right? A fall night out there under the stars. It's going to be gorgeous. And, yeah, you buy a ticket and you can't, you can't put a price tag on a smile. Oh, what a great sell. Will, you're the best. Anyway, it's going to be a great night, hopefully as great
对吧？在那儿星空下的秋夜。那会非常华丽。而且，是的，你买了一张票，你不能，你不能给微笑贴上价格标签。哦，多棒的推销。威尔，你是最棒的。总之，那会是一个很棒的夜晚，希望和
as this next guest coming up. Guys, let's get to the episode. Guys, I was racing out of the house to come be here on time. Yeah. And... Out of the house. Yeah, he had to go across the compound. Oh.
接下来要来的这位嘉宾一样棒。伙计们，让我们进入这一集吧。伙计们，我当时正从家里冲出来，为了准时赶到这里。是的。而且……从家里出来。是的，他得穿过大院。哦。
Into a separate structure. Sorry, yeah, yeah. Golf carts, a half-hour golf cart drive. Tell the listener. Wait, guys, everybody just... Oh, I thought... Well, you can keep chewing, well. Just everyone else just...
进入一个独立的建筑。抱歉，是的，是的。高尔夫球车，半小时的高尔夫球车车程。告诉听众。等等，伙计们，大家只是……哦，我以为……好吧，你可以继续嚼，威尔。只是其他人只是……
Just listen to first. God. I know. It's an audio show. Yeah. Anyway. And there is... in front of the window by the front door, lying on the ground is a small bird that had hit
只是先听着。天哪。我知道。这是一个音频节目。是的。总之。而且那里……在靠近前门的窗户前，躺在地上的是一只小鸟，它撞到了
the window, I guess, earlier, and was not yet dead, but deeply wounded, hurt. And I'm racing to you guys. I didn't have chance to stop and help. I had to call back into the house, and Amanda, I think, I hope, is tending to the young bird. But guys, I'm not good about seeing injured animals. This is the second time in five days that there's been a dead bird, a bird that was injured.
窗户，我想，早些时候，还没死，但受了重伤，受伤了。我正赶着去你们那儿。我没机会停下来帮忙。我不得不打回屋里，阿曼达，我想，我希望，正在照顾那只幼鸟。但是伙计们，我不擅长看到受伤的动物。这是五天内第二次有死鸟，一只受伤的鸟。
Remember, on Sunday, a man, came across an injured bird. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. What's going on? What if that bird tonight was sitting at the dinner table just all wrapped in bandages? And it's like, hey, I'm just going to be spending some time in your house from now on.
记得吗，周日，阿曼达，遇到了一只受伤的鸟。哦，是的，是的，是的。怎么回事？如果那只鸟今晚坐在餐桌旁，浑身缠满绷带会怎样？就像是，嘿，从现在开始我要在你们家待一段时间了。
Now it can speak. Yeah. Boy, that would be fantastic. I mean, I'll never forget, right? Michigan Frog. Isn't that the name of the frog? Yeah, Michigan J. Frog. Michigan J. Frog.
现在它会说话了。是的。天哪，那太棒了。我的意思是，我永远不会忘记，对吧？密歇根青蛙。那不是那只青蛙的名字吗？是的，密歇根·J·青蛙。密歇根·J·青蛙。
Hello, my baby. Hello, my honey. What was the lesson of that particular cartoon episode? I don't know, but every time, yeah, he said, it was somebody who he was like, oh, my God, you got to hear my, it's like saying, I have a friend who's really funny, watch, and then they don't say anything funny. I have a frog that can sing, watch,
你好，我的宝贝。你好，我的甜心。那个特定的卡通剧集的教训是什么？我不知道，但每次，是的，他说，那是某个人，他就像，哦，天哪，你得听听我的，就像是说，我有一个朋友真的很有趣，看着，然后他们什么有趣的话都没说。我有一只会唱歌的青蛙，看着，
and the frog doesn't sing around anybody else. And then he rents out Carnegie Hall, and the frog just goes, rivet. And he was like, what? Remember that? And then he got his own network, the WB, the WB, yeah. And then he got the WV, the W, the W, the W, W, W, B. Yeah.
而且那只青蛙不在任何人面前唱歌。然后他租下了卡内基音乐厅，那只青蛙只是发出，呱。然后他就像，什么？记得那个吗？然后他有了自己的电视网，WB，WB，是的。然后他有了WV，W，W，W，W，W，B。是的。
I remember. So how's everybody this morning? Good. Scotty's birthday's coming up. I'm going to take him to the Lucas Museum. Boy, speaking of Scotty, that's Scotty. You played us that music that he wrote for the college there. I mean, it's just like, that was stunning, stunning stuff. Thanks, thanks, thanks, thank.
我记得。那么大家今天早上怎么样？很好。斯科蒂的生日快到了。我要带他去卢卡斯博物馆。天哪，说到斯科蒂，那是斯科蒂。你给我们放了那段他为那里的大学写的音乐。我的意思是，那真是太棒了，太棒了。谢谢，谢谢，谢谢，谢。
It's like John Williams. I thought it was John Williams. I thought it was when I walked in, you guys were playing it, and I thought it was John Williams. He recorded it with the John Williams Orchestra, basically. Yeah, like a lot of people who played on a lot of, for John Williams. It's a compliment. I mean, it's a talented man.
就像约翰·威廉姆斯。我以为是约翰·威廉姆斯。我以为当我走进来时，你们在播放它，我以为是约翰·威廉姆斯。他基本上是和约翰·威廉姆斯管弦乐团一起录制的。是的，就像很多为约翰·威廉姆斯演奏过的人一样。这是一种赞美。我的意思是，这是一个有才华的人。
He's a great. It'll come out, thanks for saying that. It'll come out, like, in a month or so. Like, he'll post it and all that stuff. So you guys, you're taking him to the Lucas Museum. Yeah, didn't that thing? It just opened. I just read an article about that this morning.
他很棒。它会出来的，谢谢你这么说。它会在一个月左右出来。就像，他会发布它之类的。所以你们，你们要带他去卢卡斯博物馆。是的，那东西不是吗？它刚开业。我今天早上刚读到一篇关于那个的文章。
Yeah, more banana. So, yeah. Yeah, you just gave me shit, and then you fill your mouth and then start talking. Yeah. No, do it. Do the gross banana sound. Do it. No, I can't.
是的，更多香蕉。所以，是的。是的，你刚骂了我，然后你塞满嘴巴然后开始说话。是的。不，做吧。做那个恶心的香蕉声。做吧。不，我不能。
Respectable guess. No, you're doing it. No, you're doing it. Don't worry. Yeah. But so this episode is, we're in October. This episode is brought to you by October. And the Lucas Museum opened a couple of weeks ago.
受人尊敬的嘉宾。不，你在做。不，你在做。别担心。是的。但是所以这一集是，我们在十月。这一集是由十月赞助的。而卢卡斯博物馆几周前开业了。
It opened on his birthday. Yeah. And I'm very excited to go see that. Yeah. So you're going to the opening on his birthday. We can't. We're going to be in London, but we're going to come back after that. But what are you going to do with your pocket protector?
它在他生日那天开业。是的。而且我非常兴奋去看看那个。是的。所以你要去参加他生日那天的开幕式。我们不能。我们要去伦敦，但我们会在那之后回来。但是你要怎么处理你的口袋保护器？
Yeah. What kind of outfit will you guys be wearing when you go to the Lucas Museum? Full, like, cape. Tattoine. Some sort of a loose flowing robe. Oh, he's got the Tatween hat on. Oh, my goodness. Yeah, I'm super, super excited.
是的。你们去卢卡斯博物馆时会穿什么样的衣服？全套，像，斗篷。塔图因。某种宽松飘逸的长袍。哦，他戴着塔图因的帽子。哦，天哪。是的，我超级，超级兴奋。
And, you know, I hear there's not a lot of Star Wars stuff in there. No, uh-uh. It'll be hard-pressed to find something in there. No, no, truly. I think J.B. was being serious. I'm being serious. No, I just saw a video of it. Somebody took a video who's already in it, and there's tons of stars.
而且，你知道，我听说里面没有多少星球大战的东西。不，嗯嗯。你很难在里面找到什么东西。不，不，真的。我想J.B.是认真的。我是认真的。不，我刚看了它的视频。有人拍了一个已经在里面的人的视频，里面有成吨的星球大战的东西。
Of course there's tons of Star Wars stuff. All right. Just the article I read. Jason, you just caused a panic in the nerd community. I was like, what? Why would we go? Maybe what they said was... I'm calling my congressman.
当然有成吨的星球大战的东西。好吧。只是我读的那篇文章。杰森，你刚刚在书呆子社区引起了恐慌。我当时想，什么？我们为什么要去看？也许他们说的是……我要给我的国会议员打电话。
Not as much as you would think. It is much more about the... No, you're making all this up. I was reading in the New York Times this morning. Oh, really? Okay. Another bite for sure. Sorry, Jason, go ahead. Another bite of that.
没有你想象的那么多。它更多的是关于……不，你是在编造这一切。我今天早上在《纽约时报》上读到的。哦，真的吗？好吧。肯定还要再咬一口。抱歉，杰森，继续。再咬一口那个。
The karma is so instant. It's fucking bad. And then I'm going to move into this, my aloha bar. Aloha bar. Those bars are great. They're just filled with stuff you don't know. Yeah. No, there's plenty of it.
因果报应真是太快了。这他妈太糟糕了。然后我要吃这个，我的阿罗哈棒。阿罗哈棒。那些棒子很棒。它们只是装满了你不知道的东西。是的。不，里面有很多。
Why not just eat whole food? They describe it all in the back. These aloha bars, everybody. Oh, God, please. Those are your snacks. You know what I had for a snack before bed last night? Let me guess. Let me guess.
为什么不直接吃全食？他们在背面都描述了。这些阿罗哈棒，大家。哦，天哪，拜托。那是你的零食。你知道我昨晚睡前吃了什么零食吗？让我猜猜。让我猜猜。
Can we guess? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Dumplings. No. A gallon of caramel corn. Nope. Melasses. No.
我们可以猜吗？是的，是的，是的。饺子。不。一加仑焦糖爆米花。不是。糖蜜。不。
Hot wings. A can of sweet peas with butter. What? I just ate an entire can of peas. Wait, wait, what are sweet peas? Sweet peas, like a can... That's something I call somebody. Can peas.
辣鸡翅。一罐黄油甜豌豆。什么？我刚吃了一整罐豌豆。等等，等等，什么是甜豌豆？甜豌豆，就像一罐……那是我叫某人的东西。罐装豌豆。
Are you... Are you... Did you go into your doomsday bunker and just grab an extra can? What happened? Did you get some tang? Did you make a big jug of tang while you were down there? Yeah.
你是……你是……你是不是进了你的末日地堡然后随便拿了一罐？发生了什么？你喝了点唐粉饮料吗？你在下面的时候做了一大壶唐粉饮料吗？是的。
By the way, that sounds good to wash it down. Wait, I don't understand. Where did you get a can of peas from? I stock my whole pantry with peas because I like it as a snack. I just eat a whole can. Truly. 100%.
顺便说一句，那听起来很适合冲下去。等等，我不明白。你从哪儿弄来的一罐豌豆？我把整个储藏室都塞满了豌豆，因为我喜欢把它当零食。我直接吃了一整罐。真的。100%。
Like loose peas. Yeah, loose peas. Into a pot. Now, how are we doing it? Yeah, I put it on the stove in a pot. It takes like two minutes. With warm. With water.
就像散装豌豆。是的，散装豌豆。放进锅里。那么，我们是怎么做的？是的，我把它放在炉子上的锅里。大概需要两分钟。用温水。用水。
And then you strain it and you put butter on it. And then you eat it. I ate the whole thing. Sure. So you just love the taste of peas. By the way, Sean, again, again, it's not like we don't believe that you ate the whole thing. That's not the issue.
然后你把它滤干，放上黄油。然后你就吃了。我把整个都吃了。当然。所以你只是喜欢豌豆的味道。顺便说一句，肖恩，再说一次，再说一次，并不是说我们不相信你把整个都吃了。那不是问题所在。
The issue is... Or the butter. Or the butter. The issue is the thing itself. Yeah, peas is something that's just always kind of there Like parsley on a plate And you don't pay it much You don't really pay it much mind
问题是……或者黄油。或者黄油。问题是那个东西本身。是的，豌豆是那种总是有点在那里的东西，就像盘子上的欧芹。而且你不会太在意。你真的不会太在意。
That was them But you made a whole meal out of it Yeah, yeah, yeah Yeah, because they're sweet I don't know, it's like a sweet snack Sure I love, don't you like pea soup? I do
那是他们。但你把它做成了一顿完整的饭。是的，是的，是的。是的，因为它们很甜。我不知道，这就像一种甜零食。当然，我喜欢，你不喜欢豌豆汤吗？我喜欢。
Yeah This is a different That's soup, yeah These are solids Yeah Yeah, all right Well, if our guest is still up, we're going to fire up a conversation with him.
是的。这是一个不同的。那是汤，是的。这些是固体。是的。是的，好吧。好吧，如果我们的嘉宾还在，我们要和他开始对话了。
J.B., you don't want to just get rid of that aloh-hbar real quick. Let me just all unwrap the aloha bar. No, I won't. All right, now, fellas, I'm not sure how to properly introduce this guest this morning. To go through his credits would take an hour. To mention his nominations and awards would take another. He's been a steady and consistent presence in our business that is anything but steady and consistent.
J.B.，你不想赶紧把那个阿罗哈棒处理掉吗？让我把阿罗哈棒拆开。不，我不会。好吧，现在，伙计们，我不确定今天早上该如何正式介绍这位嘉宾。要列举他的作品需要一个小时。要提到他的提名和奖项需要另一个小时。他在我们这个一点也不稳定和一致的行业中一直是一个稳定和一致的存在。
For over 60 years, he has managed to act and produce some of the best, most entertaining, most respected, best-remembered projects that business has turned out. But he's also worked at a gas station where he won mobile man of the year. No, of the month. Do you hear a bird? I think the bird's okay.
60多年来，他成功地表演和制作了一些这个行业产出的最好、最有趣、最受尊敬、最令人难忘的项目。但他还在一个加油站工作过，在那里他赢得了美孚月度最佳员工。不，是月度最佳。你听到鸟叫了吗？我想那只鸟没事。
The bird's alive. He also did a full year of college at UCSB, a full single year. He was almost kidnapped at age eight And he's beaten cancer He's got a new book coming out Covers at all in fine detail But he's stopping by here today
那只鸟还活着。他还完成了在加州大学圣巴巴拉分校的一整年大学学业，整整一年。他在八岁时差点被绑架。而且他战胜了癌症。他有一本新书要出版。详细介绍了这一切。但他今天顺道过来。
To give us a few bits and pieces It's a great honor to have him here Please welcome the man behind The China Syndrome Wall Street fatal attraction basic instinct One Flew of the Cuckoo's Nest Romancing the Stone falling down The War of Roses
给我们讲一点点片段。能让他来这里是莫大的荣幸。请欢迎《中国综合症》、《华尔街》、《致命诱惑》、《本能》、《飞越疯人院》、《绿宝石》、《城市英雄》、《玫瑰战争》背后的男人。
Michael Douglas Many great films folks Michael Douglas Wow Oh my guys Douglas Oh my gosh Nice to see you
迈克尔·道格拉斯。许多伟大的电影，伙计们。迈克尔·道格拉斯。哇。哦，我的伙计们。道格拉斯。哦，天哪。很高兴见到你。
That's nice to see you too. Is it Legend Day on SmartLess? I know, I know. What a Troika. I mean, I want to call you, sir. Can I call you Michael? Call me Mikey. You can call me, Steve.
见到你也很高兴。今天是SmartLess的传奇日吗？我知道，我知道。多么棒的三人组。我的意思是，我想叫你先生。我可以叫你迈克尔吗？叫我麦基。你可以叫我，史蒂夫。
Mikey. I'll never be Mikey. Michael, anything you want to chase. You know, going through your stuff, doing the modicum of research we do here. I just, I'm just knocked out, sir. the amount of highest quality work possible that you've done with your time as well of just commercial success as well and the producing and then just the life you've lived when you're off the set. I just, I don't know how you've packed it all in. So thank God you've written a book about it. So happy you're here to share. What's the name of the book? One hell of a ride.
麦基。我永远不会是麦基。迈克尔，任何你想叫的。你知道，翻看你的东西，做我们在这里做的少量研究。我只是，我只是被震撼了，先生。你用你的时间所做的最高质量的工作，以及商业上的成功，还有制作，还有你在片场之外所过的生活。我只是，我不知道你是怎么把这一切都塞进去的。所以感谢上帝你写了一本书。很高兴你来分享。书的名字是什么？地狱般的旅程。
Okay, perfect title. That's great. Perfect title. That's great. Well, I mean, can we start near the beginning? I mean, I just, I would love to know, you know, obviously your father had a head start with things and showing you what this business is about and what it could be. How early on did you think that you might want to do that as well? Not too early. I think, no. I think probably being the son of,
好的，完美的标题。那太棒了。完美的标题。那太棒了。好吧，我的意思是，我们可以从开头附近开始吗？我的意思是，我只是，我很想知道，你知道，显然你父亲在事情上有一个领先优势，并向你展示了这个行业是什么，它可能是什么。你多早之前就想过你也想做那个？不太早。我想，不。我想大概是作为……的儿子，
my mother is an actress too. Yeah, yes. And so I was aware of the business, but I know you guys would find this hard to believe, but we are a fairly self-involved group. We like us. They talk about the order of, you know, God, our country, family, and then a career.
我母亲也是一名演员。是的，是的。所以我意识到这个行业，但我知道你们会觉得这很难相信，但我们是一个相当自我投入的群体。我们喜欢我们。他们谈论顺序，你知道，上帝，我们的国家，家庭，然后是事业。
But I think for us that are our business career, kind of comes first. So my folks got divorced at a very young age when I was like about five. They'd just gone out to California. My father just started getting a movie career. And he probably kind of acted like a guy who had never seen a girl before. So he didn't take long before my mom would say, eh, eh, I don't think this is going to work out. I'll stay in New York.
但我认为对于我们这些行业事业的人来说，某种程度上是第一位的。所以我的父母在我很小的时候，大概五岁左右就离婚了。他们刚去加州。我父亲刚开始电影生涯。他大概表现得像个从未见过女孩的家伙。所以没过多久我妈妈就会说，呃，呃，我不认为这会成功。我会留在纽约。
So let's go back to New York. kids. Yeah. So I basically grew up as a New Yorker. Yeah. As part of it as being part of the royal family, we had a small apartment on the west side facing the alley. He was on Central Park West, but it faced the alley.
所以让我们回到纽约。孩子们。是的。所以我基本上是作为一个纽约人长大的。是的。作为皇室成员的一部分，我们在西区有一个面向小巷的小公寓。他在中央公园西路，但它面向小巷。
This was 19, 1948, 49. Yeah, Central Park West facing west is not great. No. No. That's beginning. That's funny. And so I knew them both as working, working people and is, you know, how anxious we all are to get a job.
这是1948年，49年。是的，中央公园西路面向西并不好。不。不。那是开始。那很有趣。所以我知道他们都是工作的人，而且是，你知道，我们所有人为了得到一份工作是多么焦虑。
And they weren't ready to make those sort of, I think, choices between the family and stuff. So my early years was sort of bouncing back and forth between going to private schools, private schools in New York City's and all boys schools and uniforms. And then going out to California on the holidays to visit my father, whose career incrementally was continuing to improve and beginning to get a taste of that. Hollywood. Right. Did you get a feel of that
而且他们还没准备好做出那种，我想，在家庭和事情之间的选择。所以我早年是在去私立学校，纽约市的私立学校和全男校以及制服之间来回奔波。然后假期去加州看望我父亲，他的事业在逐步改善，并开始尝到那个滋味。好莱坞。对。你有那种感觉吗？
when you were back in New York and you're at school, you must have, obviously your dad, of course, as you said, started to work more and more and be, you know, was a major movie star. How did that start to impact your life when you were back kind of living in New York life? Yeah.
当你回到纽约在学校时，你一定，显然你爸爸，当然，正如你所说，开始越来越多地工作，并且是，你知道，是一位主要的电影明星。当你回到纽约生活时，那开始如何影响你的生活？是的。
Well, you know, kids are inherently nasty. Yeah, and the truth is, I don't know. I don't know. Did any of you guys go to camp or anything? Oh, yeah. Yeah. It's awful. Brutal.
嗯，你知道，孩子们天生就很讨厌。是的，事实是，我不知道。我不知道。你们中有谁去过夏令营之类的吗？哦，是的。是的。太可怕了。残酷。
Awful. So inherently, if the kids know something more about you than you know about them, and in my case, oh, his kid's a movie star. Oh, he must think he's hot shit. You know, you haven't opened your mouth yet. You know, already, he's hot shit. So you get him.
可怕。所以本质上，如果孩子们知道关于你的事情比你知道关于他们的多，而在我的例子中，哦，他的孩子是个电影明星。哦，他一定认为自己很了不起。你知道，你还没开口呢。你知道，他已经很了不起。所以你得到了它。
So you already realize that there were pluses that went along with it. But the minuses were the fact that they had something on you. They could make assumptions about who you were and what your background was, which was difficult to some point. So getting back to your question, Jason, I think that's why I thought this was the last thing that I wanted to be involved in. It was this sort of very kind of self-involved film. My mother was a, you know, she was doing soap operas back east on stage.
所以你已经意识到随之而来的好处。但缺点是他们抓住了你的把柄。他们可以对你是谁以及你的背景做出假设，这在某种程度上很困难。所以回到你的问题，杰森，我想这就是为什么我认为这是我最不想参与的事情。这是一种非常自我投入的电影。我母亲是一个，你知道，她在东部的舞台上做肥皂剧。
and so we had lannies or housekeepers and a big part of our way. But the life out there in Hollywood, watching what your dad was doing, all the things that go along with it, was that the first draw to it, or was it more about the craft and the art?
所以我们有保姆或管家，是我们生活方式的重要组成部分。但是在那里的好莱坞生活，看着你爸爸在做什么，所有随之而来的事情，那是第一次吸引力吗，还是更多关于工艺和艺术？
Because you did study quite vigorously in New York and did a bunch of theater. And like, so when was, when was, at what point, Did the craft sort of motivate you into the career versus maybe the lifestyle, or was the lifestyle ever an attraction to you? No, I think the biggest advantage of being second generation is that lifestyle is not a surprise to you.
因为你在纽约学习得相当刻苦，并且做了很多戏剧。而且，所以什么时候，在什么点，工艺某种程度上激励你进入职业生涯而不是生活方式，或者生活方式曾经对你有吸引力吗？不，我认为作为第二代最大的优势是生活方式对你来说不是惊喜。
Right, yes. You understand the insecurities, the foibles. I'm with my father and his best friends, Tony Curtis, Janet Lee, Gregory Peck, Frank Sinatra. You see them at night. You see them as real people, and their insecurities and this and that. So, you know, the reality to me was when I was in college
对，是的。你理解不安全感，怪癖。我和我父亲以及他最好的朋友，托尼·柯蒂斯，珍妮特·李，格雷戈里·派克，弗兰克·辛纳屈在一起。你在晚上看到他们。你看到他们是真实的人，他们的不安全感等等。所以，你知道，对我来说现实是当我在大学时
and had to declare a major. And it was a little different of what happened, Jason. I went to University of California at Santa Barbara after going to boys' schools my entire life, right, including prep schools, all boys' schools. And I remember my senior year, you know, in prep school, you have your college advisor. And they always reminded me of,
并且必须申报专业。而且发生的事情有点不同，杰森。我在我一生都在上男校，对吧，包括预科学校，全男校之后去了加州大学圣巴巴拉分校。我记得我的高年级，你知道，在预科学校，你有你的大学顾问。他们总是让我想起，
travel agents, you know, they had these brochures in their hands, and they would go through these brochures like a trap. You'd sit there and all of a sudden, but stop, and he pulled out this brochure, and there wasn't any Ivy League buildings or anything else. It was sort of a high shot of a guy walking down the beach carrying a surfboard in a bathing suit room. And on either side of him was a girl in a two-piece bathing suit.
旅行社，你知道，他们手里拿着这些小册子，他们会像陷阱一样翻阅这些小册子。你坐在那里，突然，但停下，他拿出了这本小册子，里面没有任何常春藤盟校的建筑或其他任何东西。这是一种高角度拍摄，一个家伙穿着泳裤拿着冲浪板走在海滩上。在他两边是一个穿着两件套泳衣的女孩。
Now this was 1963. I had never seen back east a two-piece bathing suit in my life. Better yet on a college brochure. So I said, hey, I said, I'm going. That looks good. I'm going there, man. I'm going to go there. Didn't you get accepted into Yale?
现在这是1963年。我在东部从来没见过两件套泳衣。更好的是在大学宣传册上。所以我说，嘿，我说，我要去。看起来不错。我要去那儿，伙计。我要去那儿。你没被耶鲁录取吗？
I did. Yeah. So, and you were like, yeah, but look at the bikinis. Jason, my ass was so tight in boarding schools. I knew I had to. Yeah. You had some catching up. The beaches in New Haven don't really stack up to the beaches in Santa Barbara.
我被录取了。是的。所以，而且你就像，是的，但看看比基尼。杰森，我在寄宿学校时屁股太紧了。我知道我必须。是的。你得赶上进度。纽黑文的海滩真的比不上圣巴巴拉的海滩。
Exactly. So that was actually at 16 or 18, and that was the first big decision. And a crucial decision in my life. Because for a number of reasons. It was 1963, 64, Vietnam War as just beginning. East Coast is where the most political activity was going on. Berkeley was leading the ground. The other UC campuses were picking up on it.
正是。所以那实际上是在16或18岁时，那是我第一个重大决定。也是我生命中至关重要的决定。因为出于很多原因。那是1963年，64年，越南战争才刚刚开始。东海岸是政治活动最活跃的地方。伯克利是领头羊。其他加州大学分校也开始跟进。
And also the hippie movement, which played a really important part in my life. So what happened after the first year of college at University of California, they politely said, look, I don't think you're ready for college. It wasn't really kicking you out, but why don't you take your years off at your break?
还有嬉皮士运动，这在我生活中扮演了非常重要的角色。所以加州大学第一年之后发生了什么，他们礼貌地说，看，我不认为你准备好上大学了。这并不是真的把你踢出去，但为什么你不休息一年呢？
And that's when I went to the mobile gas station, my hometown of Westport, Connecticut, and was the mobile man of the month. Those are the days of the gas station. I mean, you guys don't even remember. Those are the gas station. When you went to your gas, they had your windshield wipers watch. Yeah, check your oil. Oil was checked.
那就是我去了我家乡康涅狄格州韦斯特波特的美孚加油站，并成为了美孚月度最佳员工的时候。那是加油站的日子。我的意思是，你们甚至都不记得了。那是加油站。当你去加油时，他们会看你的挡风玻璃雨刷。是的，检查你的机油。机油被检查了。
You had your tire pressure checked. You know what you're reminding me of? Remember, you must have known this all too well. Do you remember the sound of that ding? They'd have that hose that go across when a car pulls of the thing. Do you remember that? I love that. That doesn't exist anymore.
你检查了你的胎压。你知道你在提醒我什么吗？记得吗，你一定太了解这个了。你还记得那个叮当声吗？当车子开过那个东西时，他们会有那根软管。你记得吗？我喜欢那个。那已经不存在了。
I love this. I don't know, it's nostalgic. It's true, that does not exist anymore. Yeah, yeah. Michael, was there a name for that, for that hose? Was it called the dinghose? I'm serious. Watch yourself, James.
我喜欢这个。我不知道，这很怀旧。真的，那确实不存在了。是的，是的。迈克尔，那个东西有名字吗，那个软管？它叫叮当软管吗？我是认真的。小心点，詹姆斯。
The dinghose. Let's see, let's be watching, let's eat in that banana again, J.B. Sean, you had a problem with your ding hose the other day. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So what happened? What happens?
叮当软管。让我们看看，让我们再吃那个香蕉，J.B.。肖恩，你前几天在叮当软管上出了问题。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。那么发生了什么？发生了什么？
I came back to college. After my year off, I came back to college. And I began... To Santa Barbara? To Santa Barbara. Had begun to be involved with the, let's say, the artistic group on the campus. That group that held out, hung out in the corner of the student union and raincoats and dark coats and this and that. Sure.
我回到大学了。休息一年后，我回到大学了。我开始……去圣巴巴拉？去圣巴巴拉。开始参与，比如说，校园里的艺术团体。那个在学生会角落里穿着雨衣和深色外套闲逛的团体。当然。
And was introduced to this, you know, this whole other... whole other world. And when I came back, went to the vice chancellor, I said, well, you know, you got to declare a major. I said, what? And by this time, man, by this time I'd, you know, gotten into it a little bit, man.
并被介绍给这个，你知道，这个全新的……全新的世界。当我回来时，去找副校长，我说，嗯，你知道，你得申报专业。我说，什么？而到这个时候，伙计，到这个时候我已经，你知道，稍微进入状态了，伙计。
And so I said, what do you mean? So you have to declare a major. I don't know, man. I said, and so I said, I guess the only thing I know the most about is theater. You know, my dad, I watch this. So still never having an inkling about acting or anything like that. That was when I declared theater as by major
所以我说，什么意思？所以你必须申报专业。我不知道，伙计。所以我说，我想我唯一最了解的就是戏剧。你知道，我爸爸，我看着这个。所以仍然没有关于表演之类的暗示。那是我申报戏剧作为专业的时候
and began my pursuit on that area, on that area, which I was not a natural act. No, but you seem pretty natural to me. I mean, I gather that, you know, you didn't learn how to be such a great actor in class. I bet you were, obviously, you were born with a lot of it. It's in your DNA, but can you, you? Can you recall the sort of your style and your ease with it and your talent with it growing over the years? And did you feel like you had enough under your feet when you went into, say, I would imagine the big launch was streets of San Francisco?
并开始我在那个领域的追求，在那个领域，我不是一个天生的演员。不，但你对我来说看起来很自然。我的意思是，我收集到，你知道，你不是在课堂上学会如何成为一个伟大的演员的。我敢打赌你，显然，你天生就有很多，它在你的DNA里，但你能，你吗？你能回忆起你的风格和你的轻松感以及你的天赋随着岁月的增长吗？而且你觉得当你进入，比如说，我想大发布是《旧金山街道》时，你脚下有足够的东西吗？
Did you feel that you were equipped enough to take on that role and vault you into an ability to make a living in the business? No. No. Next question. I began with major, major stage fright. Okay. I could not go on, I could not walk onto a stage without a waistbasket right off stage, which I would puke into.
你觉得你有足够的能力承担那个角色并让你有能力在这个行业谋生吗？不。不。下一个问题。我开始时有严重的舞台恐惧症。好吧。我不能上台，我不能在没有舞台旁边的废纸篓的情况下走上舞台，我会吐进去。
Really? Before I go on to stage, I had total stage fright, and I never thought I'd be overcoming. And the only reason, the only reason I think that I actually stayed at it, was to try to overcome the stage fright. And what did it? So one big thing happened in here at this time was that after my sophomore season,
真的吗？在我上台之前，我有严重的舞台恐惧症，我从没想过我会克服它。而且我认为我实际上坚持下去的唯一原因，唯一原因，是为了尝试克服舞台恐惧症。是什么做到的？所以当时发生了一件大事，就是在我的大二赛季之后，
my stepfather, William Darryd, who I grew up with, was on the board of a new theater called the National Playwrights Conference in Waterford, Connecticut. And what they would do every summer is they would put on like six new plays. And they had a small act a group that would, you know, would do these plays.
我的继父，威廉·达里德，我从小和他一起长大，是康涅狄格州沃特福德一个叫国家剧作家会议的新剧院的董事会成员。他们每年夏天都会做六部新戏。他们有一个小型的表演团体，你知道，会做这些戏。
And my first summer there, I was just sort of an apprentice kind of cleaning up. But what happened is then they sort of allowed me to be part of the company. And the focus was on the material, on the play. You were only there as an actor as a tool to make these plays better. So you would sit there and you would run through the scenes or run through the show. Then you'd sit on the sidelines and listen to the note. that the director would be giving to the playwright in ways of how to improve the quality.
我那里的第一个夏天，我只是一个学徒，负责打扫卫生。但后来发生的事情是，他们允许我成为公司的一部分。重点是材料，关于剧本。你作为演员只是一个让这些剧本变得更好的工具。所以你会坐在那里，你会排练场景或排练演出。然后你会坐在场边听笔记。导演会给剧作家关于如何提高质量的建议。
So at a very early age, right at the beginning, I learned that everything was the material. Everything was about the quality of the material. And that allowed you to get out of your head about the result of your performance. It certainly helped. It certainly helped, but it allowed me to help understand
所以在很小的时候，就在一开始，我就学到了一切都是材料。一切都与材料的质量有关。这让你不再纠结于表演结果。这肯定有帮助。它肯定有帮助，但它让我能够理解
the choices that I made professionally later on, i.e. it wasn't about the part. It wasn't about it. It's about how good, I think this is going to be a good movie. And because I had these years of formation on it, and then I was, you know, so then after school I was doing off Broadway in New York
我后来在职业生涯中所做的选择，即这不是关于角色。这不是关于它。这是关于有多好，我想这会是一部好电影。而且因为我有这些年的形成，然后我，你知道，所以学校毕业后我在纽约做外百老汇
and finally got a CBS playhouse, which he did on television, which turned out really well. And CBS back then had a film the vision. I signed a contract. I went out to California and proceeded to make five turkeys.
最后得到了一个CBS剧场，他在电视上做的，结果非常好。当时的CBS有一个电影愿景。我签了合同。我去了加州，并继续制作了五部火鸡。
Five really shitty movies. The one I remember about because CBS also owned Radio City Music Hall and the movie was shown at Radio City Music Hall and this friend of mine,
五部真的很烂的电影。我记得其中一部是因为CBS也拥有无线电城音乐厅，电影在无线电城音乐厅放映，我的这个朋友，
John Gware, who was one of the playwrights that I had met of New Neal. It called me. I said, John, do you see the show? He said, yeah, yeah. Well, what did you think? He said, Michael, let me just say there were more people up on stage with the Rockettes than there were in the audience. Yeah.
约翰·格瓦尔，是我在尤金·奥尼尔遇到的剧作家之一。他打电话给我。我说，约翰，你看了演出吗？他说，是的，是的。好吧，你觉得怎么样？他说，迈克尔，让我说，舞台上火箭女郎的人数比观众席里的人数还多。是的。
You know, not to sort of go back a little bit, but, you know, it's interesting when I hear you as a young actor and you have that experience with the playwrights and that process, that must have helped you carried you on because you've had such a prolific career also as a producer. and you had an early appreciation of what it is to build a thing that it's about the material, all that stuff. Is that true? That's exactly true. And that's why I can't emphasize it enough of how important it was not looking for parts. So anyway, after these five turkeys,
你知道，不是要稍微回顾一下，但是，你知道，当我听到你作为一个年轻演员，你有那种与剧作家的经历和那个过程，这一定帮助你坚持下去，因为你作为一个制片人也有如此多产的职业生涯。而且你很早就意识到建立一个东西是关于材料的，所有这些东西。那是真的吗？那是完全正确的。这就是为什么我怎么强调都不为过，寻找角色是多么重要。总之，在这些火鸡之后，
I was sort of sliding into television. And this is where, you know, where good luck, you know, just good grace happens for you. Two things happened to me early in my life. career was I was doing FBI's and medical centers and this and that and then streets came up and streets was a lawsuit that Quinn Martin who was a very big time producer at that time the fugitive canon Martin and he had all these shows they did they used to do Quinn had this lawsuit with this brand new network called ABC and he won the lawsuit and the result of William the
我有点滑向了电视。这就是，你知道，好运，你知道，好恩典发生在你身上的时候。我职业生涯早期发生在我身上的两件事是，我正在做《联邦调查局》和《医疗中心》之类的，然后《街道》出现了，而《街道》是一场诉讼，奎因·马丁，当时是一个非常大牌的制片人，逃亡者，加农炮，马丁，他有所有这些节目，他们过去常做，奎因和这个叫ABC的新电视网有这场诉讼，他赢了诉讼，而诉讼的结果是
lawsuit was a two-hour introduction movie to the series and 26-hour episodes committed back in the first season. So they, you know, for guys so many, he said, hey man, this is, this is a real great opportunity. It's a go show. And it starred Carl Malden. Yeah. Yeah. And Carl Malden, you know, was worshipped by Marlon Brando and was just an unbelievably hardworking actor and a really good actor. So that was five years.
系列的两小时介绍电影和第一季承诺的26小时剧集。所以他们，你知道，对于伙计们来说，他说，嘿，伙计，这是一个，这是一个真正伟大的机会。这是一个去节目。而且它由卡尔·莫尔登主演。是的。是的。而且卡尔·莫尔登，你知道，被马龙·白兰度崇拜，只是一个令人难以置信的勤奋演员和一个真正的好演员。所以那是五年。
I did 104 hours that I spent with Carl Malden. Wow. And also structurally, once again, preludes, three acts, prologues, learning structurally, you know, and what your responsibility as an actor is, and then working with different directors every week and this was so helpful. And was a tremendous opportunity.
我做了104个小时，我和卡尔·莫尔登在一起。哇。而且在结构上，再一次，序幕，三幕，序言，学习结构，你知道，以及你作为演员的责任是什么，然后每周和不同的导演合作，这非常有帮助。是一个巨大的机会。
and then the God from God that was handed down was one flow of the cuckoo's nest which was a project. Incredible. My father had developed and gone back himself to Broadway to do the show.
然后上帝传下来的上帝是《飞越疯人院》，这是一个项目。不可思议。我父亲开发了它，并亲自回到百老汇做这个节目。
It hadn't worked out. I had read in college 20th century American literature the book like everybody who was taking acid. It was their favorite their favorite novel.
它没成功。我在大学读20世纪美国文学时读过这本书，就像每个吸食酸的人一样。这是他们最喜欢的，他们最喜欢的小说。
And then as I was working away and then I sort of overheard Dad talking about selling the project. When I was there, and I said, oh, man, I never thought about producing. But Dad, please let me try to get the set up. I'll try to get it set up, you know, with you playing the part, with the production company and all this. So the original idea was for your dad to play the lead part, not you? Oh, correct.
然后当我工作时，我有点无意中听到爸爸谈论出售这个项目。当我在那里时，我说，哦，伙计，我从没想过制作。但是爸爸，请让我试着把它建立起来。我会试着把它建立起来，你知道，由你扮演角色，由制作公司和所有这些。所以最初的想法是你父亲扮演主角，而不是你？哦，对。
No, it was, it was, it was his part. How old, excuse me, how old were you at the time? And this is ambitious. Yeah, it was ambitious. I was, I started about, I was 23. Wow. I was 23 going on. Wow.
不，它是，它是，它是他的角色。请问，你当时多大？这很有野心。是的，这很有野心。我，我开始大概，我23岁。哇。我23岁。哇。
When that movie came out, that's amazing. The time the movie came out, I was 30. Okay, okay. But he was so, he tried, so then he said, well, give me a year, let me try to get it going. And so while I was doing Streets of San Francisco, which was being filmed in San Francisco, and we were shooting 26 episodes on location, so six days a week. Right? Six days a week, eight, eight and a half months straight. I was a motherfucker.
那部电影出来的时候，太神奇了。电影出来的时候，我30岁。好的，好的。但他太，他尝试了，所以他说，给我一年，让我试着让它进行。所以当我在做《旧金山街道》时，它是在旧金山拍摄的，我们在外景地拍摄了26集，所以每周六天。对吧？每周六天，八，八个半月直拍。我是一个混蛋。
I mean, I was, you know, you couldn't ask for any hard or work. At the same time, I was able to hook up with this, my partner, Saul Zanz, over at Fantasy Records in Berkeley, which is up there. So I would then go on over to Berkeley. We would work and nurture it. And so by the time I'd finished the fourth season, We were able to make the movie. Wow. And they wrote your character off to free you up to give you the time to do all the finishing work on the producing, yes?
我的意思是，我，你知道，你不能要求任何更努力的工作。同时，我能够和我的合伙人，索尔·赞茨，在伯克利的幻想唱片公司联系上，就在那里。所以我就会去伯克利。我们会工作并培育它。所以当我完成第四季时，我们能够制作这部电影。哇。他们写掉了你的角色来释放你，给你时间做所有制作的收尾工作，对吗？
Correct, Jason. But the reality is, and we all know, and I know you know, that, you know, for a network to say, I have a five-year contract with you, right, but we're going to let you out. Yeah, yeah. It doesn't happen, and it doesn't happen at all. Yeah. Well, what do you think you saw in that project that no one else saw? because you did get a series of passes there.
对，杰森。但现实是，我们都知道，我知道你知道，你知道，对于一个电视网来说，说，我和你有五年合同，对吧，但我们要让你离开。是的，是的。这不会发生，而且根本不会发生。是的。好吧，你认为你在那个项目中看到了什么别人没看到的？因为你确实在那里经历了一系列拒绝。
It did take a while to get it going. And then it does eventually go on to become the film that it wins all five major Academy Awards. You know, and you're 31. And what do you, what do you, it couldn't have been blind luck. What do you think you saw in it that everyone else ended up finally seeing? I think I saw that it was a really, really good story, you know, really, really classic a good story and I think I overcame everybody
它确实花了一段时间才开始。然后它最终成为了一部赢得所有五项主要奥斯卡奖的电影。你知道，你31岁。而且你，你，这不可能是盲目的运气。你认为你在里面看到了什么，每个人最终都看到了？我想我看到它是一个非常，非常好的故事，你知道，非常，非常经典的好故事，而且我想我克服了每个人
saying who wants to see another snake pit that was the big thing who wants to see no one's to see a picture about crazy people and I bought later while I checked out and snake pit did very well
说谁想看另一个蛇坑，那是大事情，谁想看，没人想看关于疯子的电影，而我后来查了一下，蛇坑做得很好
thank you very much it wasn't it wasn't the thing that happened but I think it was the innocence and not having been burnt yet and making mistakes and saw my partner
非常感谢。它不是，它不是发生的事情，但我想那是纯真，还没有被烧伤，犯错误，和索尔我的合伙人
sort of was the same way. And we were strictly, strictly an independent picture. But we went, you know, and I remember, so Saul and I went to talk to the directors, and most of them were up in the San Francisco Bay Area, and they were all kind of smug. And we tried to talk to them. They kind of kept their cards close to their vest.
某种程度上是一样的。而且我们严格来说，严格来说是一部独立电影。但我们去了，你知道，我记得，所以索尔和我去和导演谈话，他们大多数都在旧金山湾区，他们都有点自鸣得意。我们试着和他们谈话。他们有点把牌藏在背心下。
You really couldn't feel what it was going to be. Yeah, when did you get Milosh Forman? And we found a me lotion. And we remember looking, something told me about Milo. and a couple of his pictures, his Czech pictures. One was called the Fireman's Ball, which was in one way, was similar to Cuckoo's Nest and that all the characters took place like in one room and had the right sort of humor.
你真的感觉不到它会是什么。是的，你什么时候找到米洛什·福尔曼的？我们找到了米洛什。而且我们记得看着，有什么东西告诉了我关于米洛的事。以及他的几部电影，他的捷克电影。一部叫《消防员舞会》，在某种程度上，和《飞越疯人院》相似，所有角色都发生在一个房间里，有那种正确的幽默感。
And Milo was in the middle of sort of a breakdown. He was living in the Chelsea Hotel in New York. That's where they happen. He had a friend of his Ivan pastor, also a Czech director, and Miloche would give Yvon pastor all his information about what he wanted Yvon to tell his shrink. And then Yvonne would go instead of, Emilioch would leave, Ivan would go for Milo's to the shrink and share all the stuff and come back. So the fact that when we got the script to Milo, he flew all the way out to California.
而米洛当时正处于某种崩溃中。他住在纽约的切尔西酒店。那就是他们发生的地方。他有一个朋友伊万·帕斯托，也是一位捷克导演，米洛什会把所有他想让伊万告诉他心理医生关于他想要什么的信息给伊万·帕斯托。然后伊万会去，而不是米洛什离开，伊万会去代替米洛什看心理医生并分享所有东西然后回来。所以当我们把剧本给米洛时，他飞到了加州。
And he sat down with us. at my place up in Benedict Canyon and opened the first page and he told us exactly what he wanted to do I remember Saul and I just started crying we were just like okay here's a man who's going to share with us
他坐在我们身边。在我本尼迪克特峡谷的住处，打开第一页，他告诉我们他想做什么。我记得索尔和我只是开始哭，我们只是觉得，好吧，这是一个要和我们分享的男人
but we want so much and so how about that? When did Jack Nicholson come on board? Was that Milish's idea? Was it studio? No it was you guys? No, we tried to get Gene Hackman Gene Hackman passed
但我们想要那么多，那么那个怎么样？杰克·尼科尔森什么时候加入的？那是米洛什的主意吗？是制片厂吗？不，是你们吗？不，我们试着找吉恩·哈克曼，吉恩·哈克曼拒绝了。
at what point did your father At what point did your father say, yeah, it's not going to be for me. Go cast it. That's not the way it went down. Okay. Oh, wow. No. The moment came, the moment came when I had to go to Dad and say, Dad, we got it going.
你父亲是在什么时候说，好吧，这不适合我，你去选角吧。事情不是那样发生的。好吧。哦，哇。不。那个时刻来了，当我不得不去找我爸说，爸，我们已经开始筹备了。
But it's not going to be you play McMurphy. Wow. How'd that conversation go? Yeah. You know, careers had changed. He was in his 60s by then. Okay. And the business had changed.
但麦克墨菲这个角色不会由你来演。哇。那次谈话进行得怎么样？是啊。你知道，职业生涯已经变了。他当时已经60多岁了。好吧。而且这个行业也变了。
And it took me even a long time. you guys don't realize you can count on three fingers the good parts you have in your life you know the really good part you have in your life and this was a great part and he was hurt
而且我花了好长时间。你们没意识到，你一生中真正好的部分，用三个手指就能数得过来，你知道你生命中真正美好的部分，而这曾是一个伟大的部分，他当时很受伤。
upset I mean I gave him half of my producing deal which ended up being more money than he made than any picture he'd ever done in his life right sure which made things a little easier but it was the toughest thing I ever had to do.
很难过，我是说，我给了他我制片合同的一半，结果那笔钱比他一生中拍过的任何一部电影赚的都要多，对吧，当然，这让事情变得容易了一些，但这是我做过的最艰难的事情。
Oh, I'll bet. How long did it take to repair the kind of relationship after that? That's a good question. I talked about it in my book a lot, and I had the greatest adoration of my father. But he was rough when we were kids. He was out of that abusive generation. Yeah, you did something wrong.
哦，我敢打赌。那之后花了多长时间才修复那种关系？这是个好问题。我在书里谈了很多，我对父亲有着极大的崇拜。但我们小时候他很粗暴。他是那种虐待式教育的一代人。是的，你做错了事。
You'd get slapped. He gets spacked big time. Yeah, sir. And so we were, you know, we were pretty scared of him. And not to mention the fact that he just was this omnipotent character, you know, Christ Spartacus and the Vikings. He just larger than life. And he had a temper that went along with it. So our relationship was not as cautious growing up.
你会挨耳光。他会狠狠地打你。是的，先生。所以我们，你知道，我们很怕他。更不用说他还是个全能的角色，你知道，基督、斯巴达克斯和维京人。他简直是超凡脱俗。而且他还有与之相伴的坏脾气。所以我们成长过程中的关系并不那么亲近。
And my love for him grew and grew to the day he died in my admiration. but in the early days, it wasn't there. And that, and that seriously didn't help. Yeah, yeah. Maybe you mentioned this in the book. I don't know.
我对他的爱和崇拜一直增长到他去世的那天。但在早期，那种感觉并不存在。而且，那真的没有帮助。是啊，是啊。也许你在书里提到了这一点。我不知道。
I haven't, I really look forward to reading it, but was there a moment where you guys were able to sort of, you got over it and you guys were able to reconcile? Did you ever have the, I don't know,
我还没读，我真的很期待读它，但有没有一个时刻，你们能够，某种程度上，你们克服了它，你们能够和解？你有没有，我不知道，
what's the word, closure that you wanted from it, from this experience on that? Yeah, we did. I mean, we did, you know, at a professional point in time, which I think really was, for me, it was the year of the year of a fatal attraction
怎么说呢，你从这次经历中想要的了结？是的，我们做到了。我是说，我们做到了，你知道，在职业生涯的某个时间点，我认为对我来说，那是《致命诱惑》的一年，
followed by Wall Street. It's not believable. Three months later and winning the Oscar. Yeah, what a year. For me, finally feeling like I stepped out of the shadow of this amazing guy. You know, for the first time ever in my entire life, about two months ago, I watched Wall Street.
紧接着是《华尔街》。这简直不可思议。三个月后还赢得了奥斯卡。是啊，多么棒的一年。对我来说，终于感觉自己走出了这个了不起的人的阴影。你知道，大约两个月前，我这辈子第一次看了《华尔街》。
Yeah. Oh, wow. I just saw it. Yeah, yeah. I was blown away. Of course, I was blown away. And you say, Michael, there's three roles that are, you know, that an actor gets. You've had, I feel like you've had many.
是啊。哦，哇。我刚看完。是啊，是啊。我被震撼了。当然，我被震撼了。你说，迈克尔，演员一生中能得到三个角色，我觉得你已经演过很多了。
I know. I was going to say there's an incredible run. First of all, you mentioned fatal attraction. You can't, you don't know how many times in my life I've used the expression. I will not be ignored, Dan. Right, right, right, right. But you, was there, was there a mo? What was that moment?
我知道。我正想说这是一个不可思议的历程。首先，你提到了《致命诱惑》。你不知道我这辈子用了多少次那句台词，“我不会被忽视的，丹。”对，对，对，对。但是你，有没有，有没有一个时？那是什么时刻？
Because you did have this incredible run of these great roles. What was the first coming out of Cuckoo's Nest as a producer, and you've done streets, you've done all this stuff. What was the first film role that you were like, okay, now I'm in a whole different league here now. This is getting the attention, and now I'm getting the offered the roles I want. Do you remember that?
因为你确实经历了一连串伟大的角色。从《飞越疯人院》作为制片人出来，你拍了《街头》，你做了所有这些事情。第一部让你觉得，好吧，我现在处于一个完全不同的级别了，这引起了关注，现在我得到了我想要的角色，这样的电影是什么？你还记得吗？
Was there a signature? Well, yeah, but here's the gate. I was an Academy Award-winning producer. Yeah. But I was a television actor. Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You all know.
有没有一个标志性的时刻？嗯，是的，但关键在于。我是奥斯卡获奖制片人。是的。但我是一名电视演员。哇。是啊，是啊，是啊。你们都知道。
That's really still. It's gotten a lot better. But back then, man, it was, Two separate rails. You were in television, and I think before me, only I think it was Steve McQueen and Clint Eastwood, who had made that transition from getting into films.
那确实仍然存在。现在好多了。但在当时，伙计，那是两条平行的轨道。你是电视演员，我想在我之前，只有史蒂夫·麦奎因和克林特·伊斯特伍德完成了从电视到电影的转型。
So I got the Oscar, I set up at the production office as a producer, and I'm hanging on to what I realize is my biggest strength, which is understanding material, knowing good material, not worrying about my part, not worrying.
所以我拿到了奥斯卡，我在制片办公室以制片人身份立足，我坚持着我意识到自己最大的优势，那就是理解剧本，识别好的剧本，不担心我的角色，不担心。
And you said a good roles, but a lot of my movies, you know, Glenn Close had a great role. Sharon Stone had a lot of times it was never about my starring role. I just wanted to be in a good movie. And I think it was better to be in.
你说过好的角色，但我很多电影，你知道，格伦·克洛斯有一个很棒的角色。莎朗·斯通，很多时候这从来不是关于我的主演角色。我只是想参与一部好电影。而且我认为参与其中更好。
Yeah, but you shone through. You shone through no matter, even though you say that, despite you were, yeah, man, I mean, integral to all of those. It's what I've watched and studied and admired for so long about you, Michael, in your career, is that it's so interesting to hear you put to words
是啊，但你脱颖而出了。无论如何你都脱颖而出了，尽管你这么说，尽管你是，是啊，伙计，我是说，对所有这些电影都至关重要。这就是我长期以来观看、研究并钦佩你的地方，迈克尔，在你的职业生涯中，听到你用语言表达出来非常有趣，
what I guess I've been absorbing, which is that you've always been servicing the film, the story. I've never watched you and thought, oh, this guy is doing me a favor and giving me a performance that he thinks I bought a ticket to come see. Right, right. You've always behaved on screen assuming that the audience has bought a ticket
我想我一直在吸收的东西，那就是你总是服务于电影，服务于故事。我从来没有看着你然后想，哦，这家伙是在帮我，给我表演他认为我买票来看的东西。对，对。你在银幕上的表现总是假设观众买票是
to see the film, not you. And so you've always just disappeared and you've been us on the screen. You've been this trustworthy proxy that is experiencing whatever story is going on around you. And it's just been, it's been, it's been a real gift that you've given.
为了看电影，而不是看你。所以你总是消失了，你就是银幕上的我们。你一直是这个值得信赖的代理人，体验着你周围发生的任何故事。这真的是你给予的一份真正的礼物。
I can just speak for myself. You've given me, you have been this great proxy, this great tour guide that have brought me through so many great stories and environments and challenges and complications and decisions and successes all through your characters in these stories. It's just been stunning. I just couldn't imagine having a better career, truly.
我只能代表我自己说。你给了我，你一直是这个伟大的代理人，这个伟大的导游，带我经历了这么多伟大的故事、环境、挑战、复杂情况、决定和成功，所有这些都通过你在这些故事中的角色。这真是太震撼了。我真的无法想象有比这更好的职业生涯了。
Chase, thank you very much. It is true. The one note that I hear more than anything else from people is, you know, when I see your name, I don't know what it's going to be, but I know it's going to be good. That's exactly right.
蔡斯，非常感谢。这是真的。我从人们那里听到的最多的评价是，你知道，当我看到你的名字时，我不知道会是什么，但我知道它会很好。完全正确。
That's exactly right. Yeah, I mean, what a compliment. And I remember hearing his story once this guy was telling about a big movie star, I'm not going to name names, a big movie star went in, he was having, this is 30 years ago, and he went into a studio and a well-known studio executive, who we all know as well.
完全正确。是啊，我是说，多么高的赞美。我记得有一次听过一个故事，这家伙在讲一个大电影明星，我不点名了，一个大电影明星进去了，他当时，这是30年前的事了，他走进一家制片厂，一位我们大家都认识的知名制片厂高管。
And the movie star was saying, you know, and he came in late, and he said, I want to do this, I'm going to do that, and the executive stopped him and said, hey, motherfucker, I'll put the guard at the gate in your role. You're not the star, the movie is the star. Right, that's right. And it always stuck with me that story.
那个电影明星当时说，你知道，他迟到了，他说，我想做这个，我要做那个，高管打断他说，嘿，混蛋，我让门口的保安来演你的角色。你不是明星，电影才是明星。对，没错。那个故事一直印在我的脑海里。
Like that idea, it kind of goes back to what you were saying, Michael, just always, it's the story, it's the film, right? And it's important. Even hearing you say it now, it's like I've just absorbed that and been like, yeah, I've got to remember that. I got to remember that. So starting after that, then, you know, I got a run of good productions. because after Cuckoo's Nest
就像那个想法，它有点回到你刚才说的，迈克尔，总是，这是故事，这是电影，对吧？这很重要。即使现在听到你这么说，就像我刚刚吸收了它，然后想，是的，我必须记住这一点。我必须记住这一点。所以从那之后开始，你知道，我有一连串好的作品。因为在《飞越疯人院》之后
I had romancing the Stone which I wasn't going to play the part I couldn't get an actor to play the part you know I tried to get and then finally I was fortunate enough the studio won at Deborah Winger that's another story and then
我有《绿宝石》，我本来不打算演那个角色，我找不到演员来演那个角色，你知道，我试着找，然后最后我很幸运，制片厂想要黛博拉·温格，那是另一个故事，然后
and then and then found the studio you know had met Kathleen Turner was she'd done a sexy picture she made. No, not the heat of the night. No, with Bill Hurt. Yeah, I know what you're talking about.
然后，然后找到了制片厂，你知道，遇到了凯瑟琳·特纳，她当时拍了一部性感的电影。不，不是《夜色撩人》。不，是和威廉·赫特那部。是啊，我知道你在说什么。
I can see the poster right now. Was that before or after China Syndrome? That was after. And then China Syndrome, and originally I wasn't going to play the part, Richard Dreyf was going to play the third role. Such a great movie. And then the Juul of the Niles.
我现在就能看到海报。那是在《中国综合症》之前还是之后？那是之后。然后是《中国综合症》，最初我也不打算演那个角色，理查德·德莱弗斯本来要演第三个角色。多么棒的电影。然后是《尼罗河宝石》。
So I had like four more hits. as a producer. I happened to be in them, but didn't have parts. But I had, you know, I was developing a movie called Star Man. Oh, Jeff Bridges did. Yeah. Oh, yeah, I love that movie. I wasn't approved.
所以我又有了四部热门电影。作为制片人。我碰巧在里面演了，但没有角色。但我有，你知道，我当时正在开发一部叫《外星恋》的电影。哦，杰夫·布里吉斯演的。是啊。哦，是的，我喜欢那部电影。我没被批准。
I wasn't approved as the actor. No shit. Yeah, no, I was produced as Jeff was. You know, so there was still a lot of that for a while. We'll be right back. And back to the show. And then what was the thing that gave you sort of the box office, to be able to be the film star,
我没被批准作为演员。不是吧。是啊，没有，我是作为制片人，杰夫是演员。你知道，所以有一段时间还是有很多这种情况。我们马上回来。回到节目。那么是什么让你获得了某种票房号召力，能够成为电影明星，
was it that year of Fatal Attraction Wall Street in 87? Yeah. Okay. Yeah, that was really kind of where it was okay. It's put to bed now, or at least I did. I mean, that's bizarre to me to think, to think that it was that late. Yeah, I had some hostilities about it.
是87年《致命诱惑》和《华尔街》那一年吗？是啊。好吧。是啊，那确实是让我觉得可以了。现在尘埃落定了，或者至少我做到了。我是说，想到那竟然那么晚，对我来说很奇怪。是啊，我对此有一些敌意。
I mean, I did about the, well, about the whole television thing versus feature film, it's always been. But as a producer, though, you must have been cognizant of sort of mind, the pocketbook and what star could translate to a presumed base level of ticket sales based on what they did in the last film and all that stuff. So you were probably aware a little bit of what the studio's agenda might have been and how it kind of made sense, even though it probably didn't feel any better. I was, Jason, but I was so fortunate from the very beginning that I only went on this is the best person forward.
我是说，关于那个，嗯，关于整个电视与电影的区别，一直都是这样。但作为制片人，你一定很清楚，你知道，钱袋子，以及什么明星能转化为基于他们上一部电影表现的预设门票销售基础，诸如此类。所以你可能对制片厂的议程以及它为什么有意义有一点了解，尽管它可能感觉并不好。我是，杰森，但我从一开始就非常幸运，我只是坚持最好的方案。
I mean, I never ever took an audience's reaction into it. Another picture like that would be falling down. You know, falling down, which I love this picture that nobody thought of it was good work at all. But I just realized how important those years at the O'Neill and then all those stripped episodes really just played such an important part and reminding me about. structure and telling me able to tell a good story and also the reality that if I didn't do the part man
我是说，我从来没有把观众的反应考虑进去。另一部那样的电影是《怒火风暴》。你知道，《怒火风暴》，我喜欢这部电影，没人认为它是什么好作品。但我只是意识到我在奥尼尔剧团的那些年，以及所有那些零碎的剧集，在提醒我关于结构，以及让我能够讲述一个好故事方面，真的起到了如此重要的作用，还有如果我不演这个角色，伙计，
there's 10 other people that can... Well, you know, most of these incredible characters that you've played, they're men who are seemingly in control but they're really they're deeply flawed and what is it
还有10个人能……嗯，你知道，你演的这些不可思议的角色中，大多数都是看似掌控一切但实际上他们内心深处有严重缺陷的男人，是什么
about those characters that for you make it so fun to play and to explore and to kind of make your own I think it's just the generation that I grew up with. I think the Vietnam War made the gray area. Who's the good guys? Who's the bad guys? My dad's generations, they had white hats and black hats.
让这些角色对你来说演起来、探索起来并把它们变成你自己的东西如此有趣？我想这只是我成长的那个时代。我认为越南战争造成了灰色地带。谁是好人？谁是坏人？我父亲那一代人，他们有白帽子和黑帽子。
My generation, it's a little murky. Sure. And I seem to be attracted to the person. Exploring that. Yeah, because it does seem like, yeah, you're mentioning the generation before, there was this artifice that the male role needed to adopt or learn or carry. And then, you know, you playing these parts where the fun for the audience is watching these cracks in that veneer, in that artifice, and seeing the vulnerabilities and the humanity in these outwardly seeming put-together men.
我这一代，有点模糊。当然。而我似乎被探索这一点的人所吸引。是啊，因为看起来确实，是啊，你提到了上一代人，有一种男性角色需要采用、学习或承担的伪装。然后，你知道，你演这些角色，观众的乐趣在于看着那种外表、那种伪装下的裂痕，看到这些外表看似完美的男人身上的脆弱和人性。
Yeah. And even looking back to Cuckoo's Nest, we could not find an actress to play Nurse Ratchet. Oh, wow. Wow. Because the politics for women at that time, you don't want to be a villain. Right, right. Oh, interesting. Guys, guys love the villain part, right? We, oh, man, we want to play the villains, the most interesting part back then. Anne Grant Magnf, Colleen Doherst, Geraldine, Paige, Charlene Page. They all turned it down.
是啊。甚至回顾《飞越疯人院》，我们找不到女演员来演拉契特护士。哦，哇。哇。因为当时女性的政治环境，你不想成为反派。对，对。哦，有趣。男人们，男人们喜欢反派角色，对吧？我们，哦，伙计，我们想演反派，那是当时最有趣的角色。安妮·班克罗夫特、科琳·杜赫斯特、杰拉尔丁·佩奇、查琳·佩奇。她们都拒绝了。
Wow. They didn't want to play the part. Let me ask you guys a quick question. Yes, sir. With all of your successful careers, man, Jason, I brought you a wonderful actor, but hell of a director, man. Hell of a director, too. Thank you, sir.
哇。她们不想演那个角色。让我问你们一个简单的问题。是的，先生。凭借你们所有成功的职业生涯，伙计，杰森，我带来了一位出色的演员，但也是个了不起的导演，伙计。也是个了不起的导演。谢谢你，先生。
Sean, what can I say? You guys weren't together on Will and Grace, didn't you? I know. We did. We did. We did. We did. Yeah.
肖恩，我能说什么呢？你们在《威尔和格蕾丝》里没在一起，对吧？我知道。我们在一起。我们在一起。我们在一起。我们在一起。是啊。
How did you come about it on this? And then I just see that you're live at Hollywood. bold. So this is a whole big thing, man. I mean, it's the greatest gift. It's the greatest gift that's ever come to the three of us. This is an accident. We get to hang around and be idiots.
你是怎么参与到这个节目里的？然后我看到你们在好莱坞现场直播。大胆。所以这是一件大事，伙计。我是说，这是最伟大的礼物。这是我们三个人收到的最伟大的礼物。这是一个意外。我们有机会聚在一起，表现得像个白痴。
And we get to talk to folks like you and have these conversations. And fortunately for us, there's a bunch of people out there that are willing to listen to us. Yeah, days like today, it never feels like a job. But days like today, talking to you is just, it's unbelievable. Yeah, I mean, and. And like these are, Michael, when you were on Will and Grace, I would have never asked you these questions.
我们有机会和像你这样的人交谈，进行这些对话。幸运的是，外面有一群人愿意听我们说话。是啊，像今天这样的日子，从来感觉不到像是在工作。但像今天这样，和你交谈真是，太不可思议了。是啊，我是说，而且。就像这些是，迈克尔，当你在《威尔和格蕾丝》的时候，我永远不会问你这些问题。
But now I'm not, now in this form, I wanted you so badly. The producers told you not to, right? Yeah, I was just like blown away that I was acting with you in a scene. Can I just ask, so you do all this, I mean, again, as Jason pointed out, and we all know, you have this incredible, you know, all these incredible roles and all these incredible projects that you produced and that you shepherded and that you believed in when other people didn't. And you do all this stuff, and then you, in the last,
但现在我不会，现在在这种形式下，我太想问你了。制片人告诉你不要问，对吧？是啊，我只是被我在一个场景里和你演戏这件事震撼到了。我可以问一下吗，所以你做了所有这些，我是说，再次强调，正如杰森指出的，我们都知道，你有这些不可思议的，你知道，所有这些不可思议的角色和所有这些不可思议的项目，你制作的，你引导的，你在别人不相信时你相信的。你做了所有这些事情，然后你，在过去，
I don't forget when you did the first one, but you kind of dipped your toe and went fully into the Marvel world, and all of a sudden you're doing a whole different genre of thing. Was that like, was that just like just another gig, or was like stepping into another world for you after all that you had done? Right. Well, let me just back up a little bit, but it helps to explain it. So what I've done in the book, you know, obviously I've,
我不记得你什么时候做的第一个，但你有点试水，然后完全进入了漫威世界，突然之间你就在做一种完全不同类型的作品。那就像，那只是另一份工作，还是在你做了所有那些事情之后，对你来说就像踏入另一个世界？对。好吧，让我稍微倒退一点，但这有助于解释它。所以我在书里所做的，你知道，显然我，
My child, I think is pretty interesting in terms of my mother being Bermudian and my father, a Russian Jew, and how they came together at Academy, and all that stuff. And growing up. But then what I decided to do, as a producer, a book that really meant a lot to me was a book called Memo by David O. Selznick. And if you ever get a chance or ever interest to know what a producer does, read memo.
我的童年，我认为在关于我母亲是百慕大人，我父亲是俄罗斯犹太人，以及他们如何在学院相遇，所有这些事情方面都相当有趣。还有成长过程。但后来我决定做的是，作为制片人，对我意义重大的一本书是戴维·O·塞尔兹尼克写的《备忘录》。如果你有机会或者有兴趣了解制片人做什么，读读《备忘录》。
So what I thought I would do rather than just continuing my history was I took 10 chapters and I took 10 chapters I took 10 movies and I go in depth I mean a whole length 30, 40 pages
所以我认为我能做的，而不是仅仅继续我的历史，我选了10个章节，我选了10个章节，我选了10部电影，我深入探讨，我是说，整整30、40页
on each of them talking about how it was created and initiated what the steps were that came through it all what personal involvements there might have been in the making of it. And so that takes up a
关于每一部电影，谈论它是如何被创造和发起的，经历了哪些步骤，在制作过程中可能有什么个人参与。所以这占据了
good chunk. And then for me, I remember I got cancer. I got stage four cancer and things weren't looking great. And so this is moving
很大一部分。然后对我来说，我记得我得了癌症。我得了四期癌症，情况看起来不太好。所以这是在
on after a whole crux of stuff. And after my cancer and after I survived and got out of it. I was really fortunate enough to have this Liberace project with Stephen Soderberg and Matt Damon and Candelabra, which was great.
经历了一大堆事情之后继续前进。在我患癌之后，在我幸存下来并走出来之后。我真的很幸运能有这个与史蒂芬·索德伯格和马特·达蒙合作的《烛台背后》的利伯拉齐项目，这很棒。
And then I just said, well, look, what haven't I done? What do I want to do now that mortality is more of an interesting subject for me than it was before? And I said, well, you know, I've never done any green screen. I haven't done a green screen picture and that was how that that sort of started
然后我就说，好吧，看，我还没做过什么？现在死亡对我来说是一个比以前更有趣的话题，我该做什么？我说，好吧，你知道，我从来没做过任何绿幕。我没拍过绿幕电影，这就是那件事开始的方式，
and so you know I looked around the agents and the Ant Man thing came up and it was fascinating and I'm sure you guys are familiar with green screen but you know it's another type of acting it's interesting
所以你知道，我环顾了一下经纪人，然后《蚁人》的事情出现了，这很迷人，我相信你们熟悉绿幕，但你知道，这是另一种表演，很有趣，
it's weird and some people are really good at it and then the other thing is they said what else happens you've done Well, I love comedy. I love comedy. I'm not particularly good at it, but I just appreciate it. I never know why it's not nominated for Oscars every year.
很奇怪，有些人真的很擅长，然后另一件事是他们说还有什么发生？你做过，嗯，我喜欢喜剧。我喜欢喜剧。我不是特别擅长，但我只是欣赏它。我从来不知道为什么它每年没有被提名奥斯卡。
We all appreciate comedians and funny people. So the situation with Chuck Lloyd Allen Arkin. Oh, yeah. The Comiskey Method, yeah. So I said, man, what a chance to learn, you know, fuck, to learn comedy. I mean, Chuck Lorry said. Alan Arkin.
我们都欣赏喜剧演员和有趣的人。所以和查克·洛里、艾伦·阿金的情况。哦，是的。《柯明斯基理论》，是啊。所以我说，伙计，这是一个学习的机会，你知道，该死，去学习喜剧。我是说，查克·洛里说。艾伦·阿金。
So I did that. I did that. And then finally, I said, I've never done a period picture. Every movie I make is about contemporary situations and all of that. So the Ben Franklin series came up. Eight episodes took all year or that. And after that, I realized I was tired, you know, deeply tired.
所以我做了那个。我做了那个。最后，我说，我从来没拍过年代戏。我拍的每一部电影都是关于当代情况之类的。所以本·富兰克林的系列出现了。八集，花了一整年。在那之后，我意识到我累了，你知道，深深地累了。
But a lifetime, a lifetime of tired. and I sort of stopped working, not retired, stop working, but I love not working. I love not working. Well, it's given you a chance to sit and review how well, how well you have spent your years. I mean, good God. You know what, Michael, we ask a lot of that.
但一辈子的疲惫。我有点停止工作了，不是退休，是停止工作，但我喜欢不工作。我喜欢不工作。好吧，这给了你一个机会坐下来回顾你度过了多么好，多么好的岁月。我是说，天哪。你知道吗，迈克尔，我们问了很多这样的问题。
It's funny, you just answered a thing. We ask a lot of people, we say, you know, you've done this, and you've been, you're known for this genre or whatever, and we say, is there anything that you haven't done? And I like the idea that you kept asking yourself, what is the thing I haven't done and really gone for it and there's a sort of
很有趣，你刚刚回答了一件事。我们问很多人，我们说，你知道，你做过这个，你以这种类型闻名，或者其他什么，我们说，有什么你还没做过的吗？我喜欢你不断问自己，我还没做过什么，并真正去追求它的想法，而且有一种
I think that's a great way to approach it right to like how can I challenge myself now is that what you would say to young actors to have that mindset well I don't know what to say to him now but it's so damn tough it is so damn man
我认为这是一种很好的处理方式，对吧，就像我现在该如何挑战自己？你会对年轻演员说这是那种心态吗？嗯，我不知道现在该对他们说什么，但这太该死地艰难了，这太该死地，伙计，
you know no there's no I mean casting you don't see a casting agent anymore you got to self tape they never even have offices anymore You go in and see your casting agent, you know, and they get to know. It's so tough. I've got three kids, all who are actors, they're doing okay. But it's tough.
你知道，不，没有，我是说选角，你再也见不到选角导演了，你必须自录试镜，他们甚至再也没有办公室了。你进去见你的选角导演，你知道，他们会了解。这太难了。我有三个孩子，都是演员，他们做得还可以。但这很难。
But to finish this off, so all that happened, then back when I had the cancer, there was a guy named Shane Salerno who, it did a rewrite for me really early on, and I was shocked how few people reached out to me with cancer. Maybe something about cancer. They don't want to get, you know, but nobody, nah, you get much, Shane, who I hardly knew, he every day would write me these, you know, you can do it, kick it, you're going to make,
但为了结束这个话题，所以所有这些都发生了，然后当我患癌时，有一个叫肖恩·萨莱诺的人，他在很早的时候为我做了一次重写，我很震惊很少有人在我患癌时联系我。也许是关于癌症的某种东西。他们不想，你知道，但没人，不，你得到很多，肖恩，我几乎不认识他，他每天都会给我写这些，你知道，你能做到，打败它，你会没事的，你会，
you're going to be fine, no, you can't. Anyways, Shane's got a literary agency kind of company now, and then he just kept pushing me, hockey me, about doing a book, and doing a book, and then I thought about it, and I think, you know, between dad and I, now we got 90 years, 90 years in the first. In the film industry, 160 movies.
你会好起来的，不，你不能。总之，肖恩现在有一家文学代理公司，然后他一直催我，缠着我，关于写一本书，写一本书，然后我想了想，我想，你知道，我和我爸，现在我们有90年，90年的第一代。在电影行业，160部电影。
My dad was a very prolific, he wrote about 10 books. So just for a legacy, I figured, you know, I would keep it going for a legacy to write the book. And then also for my memory, because you forget a lot of shit. Were you happy with your level of recall? I have a hard time remembering last week. But, like, what was that process like? I would imagine you wouldn't know how good it's going to be
我爸非常多产，他写了大约10本书。所以为了传承，我想，你知道，我会为了传承继续写这本书。而且也为了我的记忆，因为你会忘记很多狗屁事。你对自己的回忆水平满意吗？我很难记住上周的事。但是，那个过程是什么样的？我想你不会知道它会有多好
until you start getting into it. But it sounds like it's crystal clear on all of this incredible detail. Jason, I'll tell you my secret right now. Hire someone to start looking, going back over your diary and just start placing it together each year because you have no idea. And then in the book I talk about it a lot, where the years of some heavy drug use messes up.
直到你开始深入其中。但听起来你对所有这些不可思议的细节都非常清楚。杰森，我现在就告诉你我的秘密。雇个人开始寻找，回顾你的日记，然后开始每年把它拼凑起来，因为你根本不知道。然后在书里我谈了很多，关于那些大量吸毒的岁月是如何搞砸的。
And be careful what you wish for because all of a sudden, I had a big production company. I could finance movies. I had people running it. I lost an ability to pick one thing at a time. And I was a little overwhelmed. Yeah. You know, had issues with my son.
而且小心你所祈求的，因为突然之间，我拥有了一家大型制片公司。我可以为电影融资。我有员工在运营它。我失去了挑选一件事的能力。我有点不知所措。是啊。你知道，和我儿子之间有问题。
He was in federal prison for seven and a half years, my first marriage. So I looked back and happy. they're talking about the demise and the downfall of cocaine for one. Yeah. Same. Same. When you do look back
他在联邦监狱待了七年半，我的第一次婚姻。所以我回顾过去，很高兴。他们谈论可卡因的消亡和垮台。是啊。一样。一样。当你回顾过去
and you've written this book and you talk about all these things and these are just life, right? I mean, these are things that happen in life. And I feel like now we're all in our mid to late 50s could play, easily could play 40s, right? J.B. 30s, maybe.
你写了这本书，你谈论了所有这些事情，这些只是生活，对吧？我是说，这些是生活中发生的事情。我觉得现在我们都处于50多岁到快60岁，可以演，很容易可以演40多岁，对吧？J.B. 30多岁，也许。
But, you know, when you look, back are you are you despite the things that you know you had the great success and thing in and in tough times when you look back to you go like hey you know what it kind of you feel okay about it in that way like do you feel oh shit yeah I mean
但是，你知道，当你回顾过去，你是否，尽管你知道你取得了巨大的成功，经历了艰难的时刻，当你回顾过去时，你会觉得，嘿，你知道吗，它有点，你对此感觉还好，是那种方式吗？就像你觉得，哦，该死，是啊，我是说
yeah well first of all you know Hollywood royalty I mean you know which really this is netbo thing really pisses me off because I don't know a career where a father or mother don't try to help their son or daughter
是啊，好吧，首先，你知道，好莱坞皇室，我是说，你知道，这个“星二代”的事情真的让我很生气，因为我不知道有哪个职业，父亲或母亲不试图帮助他们的儿子或女儿
getting into their business and this and that. And why they picked on this because of the well-known aspect of it. But yeah, no, like I said, what a ride, man. It's been unbelievable. And other than too much drug abuse, I can't, you know. Sure. Sorry, J-B, I was going to say, it's funny you say the NEPO thing. It's like, we don't chase down when we see a plumbing truck
进入他们的行业，诸如此类。为什么他们因为众所周知的方面而挑剔这一点。但是的，不，就像我说的，多么棒的旅程，伙计。这简直不可思议。除了太多的药物滥用，我不能，你知道。当然。抱歉，J-B，我正想说，你说“星二代”的事情很有趣。就像，当我们看到一辆管道卡车时，我们不会去追究
that says McGlynn and sons. Exactly. Hey, you nepo asshole. That's what I was going to say. It's not exclusive to the entertainment industry. There are sons and daughters of... But they make it like it's like we're the only one, you know. Well, you manage to weather that all very well, seemingly.
上面写着“麦格林父子”。完全正确。嘿，你这个星二代混蛋。我正想说这个。这并不是娱乐业独有的。有……的儿子和女儿。但他们表现得好像，好像我们是唯一一个，你知道。好吧，你设法很好地度过了这一切，看起来。
Is there something that you can say to the children of parents? Our kids or kids in the enterprise, but kids in any industry that feel like they might have a birth. of living through or up to the shadow of the generation before them. Is there something that really helped you navigate that as successfully as he did? Recognizing good material. I mean, not counting on it. I mean, getting something, the problem that we all have is we don't play an instrument
有什么话可以对父母的孩子们说吗？我们的孩子或行业里的孩子，但在任何行业里，觉得他们可能有一种活在他们上一代阴影下或达到他们上一代高度的负担的孩子。有什么真正帮助你像他那样成功地驾驭这一点的东西吗？识别好的剧本。我是说，不指望它。我是说，得到一些东西，我们都有的问题是我们不演奏乐器
and we don't paint or we don't write. You know, we're standing there. But a good piece of material, man, a good piece of material helps the, helps things along well. But personally, that sort of conversation you have with yourself about, am I even going to try to live up to or even exceed what has come before me?
我们不画画，我们也不写作。你知道，我们站在那里。但一个好的剧本，伙计，一个好的剧本有助于，有助于事情顺利进行。但就个人而言，那种你和自己进行的关于，我是否甚至要尝试达到或甚至超过我之前的人的对话？
What was it that you identified in yourself that gave you kind of the inner strength to do that? I think it was inherited from my father who had incredible stamina, tenacity, was a motherfucker. And, you know, it was just really,
是什么让你在自己身上识别出赋予你那种内在力量去做这件事的东西？我想那是从我父亲那里继承来的，他有不可思议的耐力、韧性，是个混蛋。而且，你知道，这真的，
really, really tough. Yeah. And could, you know, hang on there. This is, as we all know, this is not a business
真的，真的很难。是啊。而且能够，你知道，坚持下去。这是，正如我们所知，这不是一个如果拒绝就会让你屈服的行业，你知道？拒绝是燃料。我认为它让你更坚强、更强大。而且我认为，必须创造你自己的身份。
if rejection is, is going to mend you over, you know? It's rejection is the fuel. I think it makes you tougher and stronger. And I think, have to create your own identity.
你必须相信自己，而不是试图成为亲戚的形象。这对生活来说是真的。因为突然之间，我现在82岁了，我最近刚说，嘿，伙计，有了这一切，没有很多两代电影明星，你知道我的意思吗？不，先生。我叫不出名字。所以拍拍自己的背，伙计，而且，你知道，让自己拍拍自己的背，伙计。而且，你知道，得到……
You have to trust in yourself rather than try to become an image of a relative. That's true for life. Because for all the sudden, when I just, I'm 82 now and I've just recently said, hey, man, with all this, there's not a lot of two-generation movie stars, you know what I mean? No, sir. I can't name that. So pat yourself on the back, man, and, you know, getting, get to get yourself on the back, man. and, you know, getting...
该死。是啊。好吧，你先生，那本来会是你书的另一个很棒的替代标题。一个大大的，大大的拍拍背，因为，天哪，你做到了。我本来想叫它《在我忘记之前》。但是……等等，等等，那是个很棒的标题。
Fuck. Yeah. Well, you sir, that would have been another great alternate title for your book there. A big, big pat on the back, because, my God, you get it up. I was going to call it before I forget. But... Wait, wait, that's a great title.
但他们都说，什么，他们以为你有阿尔茨海默症？这是什么问题？他们也……是啊，是啊。听我的。你提到你让人翻遍了你的日记之类的，但我真的合法地想知道。这些年来，你是否一直很好地保持着
But they all said, what, they think you got Alzheimer's? What's this problem? They also... Yeah, yeah. Take it for me. You mentioned that you had somebody go through all your diaries and stuff, but I actually am legit want to know. Have you been good about keeping...
一本非常好的日记，记录你做过的所有事情？哦，不，我根本没有日记。我是说，我只有我的秘书，你知道，我的地址。我的地址，我会，我是说，我忘记了我哪一年拍了一部电影。嗯哼。然后慢慢地做。然后我很幸运能和足够多记忆力比我好的演员合作。哦，太棒了。
a really good diary all these years of stuff that you've done? Oh, no, I have no diary at all. I mean, I just have my secretaries, you know, my address. My address where I would, I mean, I forget what year I made a movie. Uh-huh. And then slowly doing that. And then I was fortunate enough to work with enough actors who had better memories than I did. Oh, great.
是啊，当然。哦，太棒了。好吧，听着，我要让你走了。我非常感谢你做这件事。并和我们交谈。我知道一旦我读了这本书，我会再次感谢你把它全部写在纸上。所以非常，非常感谢你所做的一切，
Yeah, for sure. Oh, great. Well, listen, I'm going to let you go. And I cannot thank you enough for doing this. and talking with us. And I know once I read the book, I'm going to thank you again for putting it all down on paper. So a huge, huge thanks to all you've done,
包括今天和我们在一起的这一小时。是啊，谢谢，迈克尔。我很高兴能有这种刺激。我们会感激的，伙计们。你们做得很好。所以继续保持。谢谢，迈克尔。好吧。
including this hour with us today. Yeah, thanks, Michael. I'm glad for the thrill. We'll appreciate it, guys. You do a wonderful job. So keep it up. Thanks, Michael. Okay.
是啊。我们在那里见。保重。多么刺激。好的。谢谢你，先生。谢谢，迈克尔。再见。
Yeah. We'll see you there. Take care. What a thrill. All right. Thank you, sir. Thanks, Michael. Bye-bye.
好吧，那是，我是说，我们甚至没谈到《致命诱惑》。我们没，我们没谈到《本能》或《心理游戏》。我知道。我知道。
Well, that was, I mean, we didn't even get to fatal track. We didn't, we didn't get to basic instinct or the game. I know. I know.
就像，我想问他关于《致命诱惑》。我不会被忽视的，丹。他和丹尼·德维托的关系，那仍然，我知道。
Like, I wanted to ask him about fatal attraction. I will not be ignored, Dan. His relationship with Danny DeVito that still I know.
杰森？我知道。我想问，但我不知道。让我们把他带回来。让我们为这家伙做两期。我觉得迈克尔·道格拉斯至少需要两集。是啊，当然。
Jason? I know. I wanted to ask, but I didn't know. Let's bring him back. Let's do a two for this guy. I think Michael Douglas needs minimum two episodes. Yeah, for sure.
他所做的事情真是太震撼了。好吧，很有趣。当他在《威尔和格蕾丝》时，我就想，我想问他关于所有这些。然后他今天来了，我就想，
Really stunning what he's, what he's done. Well, it's funny. When he was on Will and Grace and I was like, I want to ask him about all that. And then he's on today, I was like,
我想问他关于所有这些。但我都没做。做不到。不，但是……得读他的书。是啊。是啊，我想你得读他的书，他会……但这只是……
I want to ask him about and all that. And I didn't do either. Can't do it. No, but... Gotta read his book. Yeah. Yeah, I guess you got to read his book, which he'll... But it's just...
这太震撼了，他说，你知道，是啊，走出像柯克·道格拉斯这样的人的阴影很难。这，你知道，就像他说的，斯巴达克斯，基督，不仅仅是孤独。是啊，是啊，是啊。而且不……他不仅做到了。
It's stunning, and he was saying, you know, yeah, it's hard to come out to step out from the shadow of somebody like Kirk Douglas. It's, you know, like as he said, Spartacus for Christ, just not alone. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And not... He not only did it.
我是说，他做到了……他超越了他父亲的遗产。是啊，他真的做到了。而且因为他有这么多角色，如此……不同，并且在这么多十年和几代欣赏他作为电影明星的人中持续了这么久，是啊，嗯，这，这，这很了不起，真的了不起。我总是把《致命诱惑》作为完美的电影场景来参考，场景对场景，就像它构建的方式，是不可思议的，而且你知道
I mean, he did it... He exceeded his father's legacy. Yeah, he really did. And because he had so many roles that were so... different and was so long-lasting over so many decades and generations of people who appreciate him as a movie star yeah um it's it's it's remarkable truly remarkable i always referenced fatal attraction is the perfect movie scene to scene like just the way it's built is is incredible and you know
那个，你知道那个不同的结局，对吧？那是阿德里安·莱恩，是啊，阿德里安·莱恩，莱恩，莱恩，那是什么，是啊，是啊，他很棒，但你知道她最后并没有被该死地爆头。最初。她自杀了。她割开了自己的喉咙。真的吗？是啊。你可以在网上看到。他们拍了吗？
that you know that different ending right is that adrian lyne yeah adrian lyne line line what's that yeah yeah he's amazing but you know she wasn't shot in the fucking head at the end originally She killed herself. She sliced her own neck. Really? Yeah. And you can see it online. Did they shoot it?
是啊，你可以看。是啊，这很疯狂。而且我认为整个结局。所以他们测试了那个，但它没有。完全正确。观众们说，嗯，那不太令人满意。我想看她被，你知道，其他人杀死。哦，哇。
Yeah, you can watch it. Yeah, it's wild. And I think the whole end. So they tested that and it didn't. That's exactly right. And the audience is like, well, that's not very satisfying. I want to see her get killed by, you know, somebody else. Oh, wow.
所以，是啊。看到它很疯狂，因为她，然后她陷害了他，因为他的指纹在她自杀用的刀上，然后警察出现了。是啊。哦，而且，你知道，另一件事是她，有一个非常可靠的不在场证明。再见！再见！
And so, yeah. It's wild to see it because she, and then she frames him because his fingerprints are on the knife that she kills herself with and then the cops show up. Yeah. Oh, and, you know, the other thing is she, had a really solid alibi. Bye! Bye!
太快了！再见！Smartless。Smartless是由贝内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆贾夫100%有机且手工制作的。Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
That's so fast! Bye! Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太快了！再见！Smartless。Smartless是由Bennett Barbico、Michael Grant Terry和Rob Armjarf百分之百有机且手工制作的。Smartless。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。